رغم التحذير روسيا من استهداف السفن التي
تستخدم الموانئ الاوكرانيه ابحرت اول
سفينه شحن تجاريه ديسا عبر ممر ملح جديد
في خطوه مهمه حسب وصف
اوكرانيا خطت لتو خطوه مهمه على صعيد
استعاده حريه الملاحه في البحر الاسود اول
سفينه مدنيه اتبعت الممر الانساني
الاوكراني الجديد انطلاقا من ميناء متجهه
الى البوسفور بالنسبه لهذا الخبير فان
مغادره سفينه الحاويه وهي ترفع علمهم كونج
حاله استثنائيه
في الوقت الراهن لن اتحمس اذ انني اعتقد
انها حاله خاصه في شمال غرب البحر الاسود
فلانها سفينه ترفع علمه كونغو والصين
سيكون لها تاثير على تطور الوطن من الواضح
ان الصين تتمتع بنفوذ كبيره على روسيا ولن
ترغب موسكو في تنفيذ اي نوع من العمليات
التي رايناها في وقت سابق من هذا الاسبوع
ضد بكين منذ
روسيا الشهر الماضي العمل باتفاق الحبوب
الذي تم التوصل اليه بواسطه من الامم
المتحده والتركيا صعدت من هجماتها على
البنى التحتيه لبناء البحر الاسود
الاوكراني والمرافق التي تستخدمها لتصدير
الحبوب عبر نهر الدانوب وهو طريق رئيسي
تستخدمه كييف لتصدير المواد الغذائيه خلال
الحرب الليل الثلاثاء الاربعاء نفذت
طائرات المسيره الروسيه هجمات الحقت
اضرارا بمخازن الحبوب في ميناء على نهر
الدانوب واشنطن نددت بهذه الهجمات واعتبرت
انها تظهر ببساطه ان بوتين لا يكترث
بالامن الغذائي العالمي هذا وضعت موسكو
الى العوده الى الاتفاق الخاص بصادرات
الحبوب الاوكرانيه